there are people here in Houston who say
they got bad advice before the storm hit
shark Strassman is here with that part
of the story mark reporting over again
we you talked about there's been so many
9-1-1 calls that have poured in that
responders have how to prioritize
life-threatening situations get a
response 24/7 everyone else has to wait
until daylight and some victims are now
complaining they should have been told
to evacuate stuck now waiting for help
these go on so have the rescues the
rising water is everywhere
pushing people in America's fourth
largest city out of their homes some
even spent the night sleeping at gas
stations in this case the flooding will
be very slow to recede so we are seeing
catastrophic flooding and this will
likely likely to expand and will likely
persist FEMA administrator said this
morning they expect 450,000 disaster
victims to file for assistance and
anticipate more than 30 thousand to be
placed in temporary shelters local
officials are having to rescue a lot of
people getting in their cars and driving
into flooded areas you're doing a couple
things one you can kill yourself to
you're gonna put the combatants people
in danger and it's pulling resources
away from the people that truly need it
resources are being stretched the Coast
Guard and other agencies have joined the
rescue effort but some victims in
Houston are still waiting for help
gervasio one zine told us she's been
stuck in the waters alongside a 95 year
old man since yesterday morning
they need help out here because they're
starting to rain and thunder agita and
we can't take any more rain harvey is
not expected to blow over anytime soon
some of the city's most vulnerable still
need help what I'm saying to estonians
let's be very patient
Houston's mayor Sylvester Turner is
standing by his decision not to order a
mandatory evacuation what's the right
decision in terms of their safety and
always we must put the interests of the
city of Houston and Houstonians
first FEMA has deployed 1,800 employees
to Texas Houston will need every last
one of them with the scope of this
disaster that's right I feel like the
officials that we've heard from say that
that the resources did not meet the
demand yet and again there's so much
demand I mean they have to prioritize
okay what is an emergency and the
definition of emergency keeps rising
with these waters thank you Mark